[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-You've never acted...
-No.
-You felt it.
-And you've actually asked to
not act with me.
-We have acted.
We did that thing with the --
[ Mimicking instrument ]
In the nest.
We've [bleep] done it.
-[ Laughing ]
-Do you remember that?
-That's some of my best work.
-You were...
-I had a little hat on
or something.
-Yeah, you were like,
you were in a bird's nest.
-We've acted.
-[ Laughing ]
-We have acted.
-Do you remember that?
-Yeah.
-Oh, my God.
-That was a classic.
-That was.
-That, I have to say, I have
looked that up now and again,
just to cheer myself up,
'cause that was...
-That was out there.
-That was.
-Oh, I was Goat Leg Greg.
-Goat Leg Greg!
-Yeah, we did it once.
We did it once.
[ Both laugh ]
I was a man with goat legs
and I would tell riddles.
-Yeah.
-And then you were
Gilvin of the Tree.
[ Both laugh ]
-It's all coming back to you.
-Yes.
-Gilvin of the Tree.
-You were Gilvin of the Tree.
-That's right.
-And we had special teeth
made for you.
-And they kept falling out
all the time.
♪♪
-And this is...
Pearls of Wisdom
with Goat Leg Greg.
[ Laughing ]
Gilvin of the Tree,
show yourself!
-It's Gilvin of the Tree.
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Playing recorder ]
Commence thy pearls, Greg.
[ Muffled words ]
[ Laughter ]
..."American Idol."
-What in the...
That was one of the weirdest
sketches we ever did.